- [Interviewer] Okay, all right so Asher
- Yes
- [Interviewer] Asher
where did you grow up,
where are you from?
- I'm originally from Phoenix, Arizona.
My family is from the Midwest,
but I lived with my dad
when I was very young,
my great-grandmother died
and we moved into her house
in northern Arizona and never left.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- Abusive, but fun.
I was a skateboarder so I had lots of fun.
So the turmoil at my home
being from a broken family
and bouncing back and forth to
step-parents and weekend dad
and stuff like that sent me to
the street as a skateboarder
and that's what gave me
my identity as a young man
because everybody looks for something
to attach themselves to even
if you have a good home life,
and so for me, I found that in the street,
and I never turned back.
- [Interviewer] And, so you
came to LA at what point?
- I've actually am state raised
so I did my first prison term here in CYA
when I was about fourteen or fifteen
and I was arrested in Indio,
California crossing the border
in a stolen vehicle that I was unaware of.
My friends said hey, you
wanna go to Riverside,
and I said yeah sounds great,
and I fell asleep because
it was a long drive,
and on the way back they
said hey, we got pulled over
tell the cops it's your car you know?
You're a juvenile, you won't go to jail.
I learned really quickly
from that point on, you know,
that the law and me have
had a long relationship
because I don't go with
the flow, you know?
So whatever someone tells me to do,
I typically tend to do the opposite.
- [Interviewer] Where do you think you got
that personality trait?
- My grandmother.
(interviewer laughs)
She was very stubborn.
She was an artist, a
schoolteacher, she made pottery
and she was actually
the one that raised me
so eating vegetables, drinking water,
being a good hearted person,
all those traits come from my grandmother,
but the second that you go outside
you have to hide those
things and bury them
in order for self-preservation
and not necessarily put on
this facade of a tough guy
but you gotta put those things to a side
so I'll say I'm a split-personality
but I'm a chameleon in a sense
where I can change who I
am sometimes on an instant
but only for safety
reasons perhaps, you know?
But my good nature comes
from my grandmother.
- [Interviewer] So do you
have kids of your own?
- Yes, I have five children
and my oldest daughter
is in her mid-twenties
and her name is Ashley.
I had her when I was very
young and at that time
graffiti was something
that was a big deal to me
along with skateboarding.
So I started writing my
daughter's name as Asher
as a way to show her how
much that I cared about her
and so, as she was growing
up she would see this
around the city and around town
and her friends when
she got older would say
oh look, there's your...look
look there's your name!
Your dad loves you so
much he writes your name!
And she's the polar opposite of me.
When I say that, I mean
successful, smart, intelligent
and not a vandal and so
when you ask her her name
she says Ash.
When she signs her name
Ash-one but Asher is me
and Ashley is my daughter.
All of my children not only like graffiti
or either do it themselves
but they don't have a real love for it,
it's just something that they enjoy
but I have five children and a grand child
and I couldn't be happier.
- [Interviewer] Did you raise them?
- Yes, except for my youngest
two, I have been incarcerated
but from birth until
my daughter was sixteen
she never went to day care,
she never went to grandma or grandpa's.
I became a tattooer simply
for the fact to be able to
facilitate being a stay at home parent.
So my first two kids are
very lucky to have had me
as such a big influence in their life
and I think the reason why
they are such good, successful
people and not like me is
a big testament to that.
- [Interviewer] So, what
do you call yourself?
A tagger, a graffiti artist?
- I'm one of Los Angeles,
California's most prolific
graffiti writers because
not only do I dominate
the visual supremacy of downtown
LA with my block letters
and I paint in broad daylight
but I don't hide who I am
and I don't hide my face
because my grandmother told
me when I was very young
if you have to sneak to
do something it's wrong
and so this is very confusing
to me because this now means
that smoking marijuana,
cussing and spray painting
is something that society
might deem to be negative
but I don't wanna offend my grandmother.
And so she's like well
I wouldn't do it then
if you're concerned about offending me.
But this is who I am.
Well then you should be who you are.
Well now I'm confused
so how do I be who I am
and not offend her?
So what she's trying to say is
you just have to do what makes you happy.
And so I decided that what
I'm doing is not a crime
if I don't believe it's a crime.
So by changing the color of
the surface a millimeter thick
might be something that society deems
not only a crime but a felonious crime
based upon how much property damage
and then can result in
not only incarceration
but community service,
restitution and even embarrassment
being dragged to your court
and all kinds of things
simply because you're expressing yourself
in a way that's not conducive
to what society deems
but this is very strange
because if you paint a mural
then you will be not only celebrated,
but you will be financially compensated.
So if I choose to go and put my art here,
that's not on somebody's personal property
I can be arrested and I just think that
that is ridiculous and fuckery
and I don't agree with it
because society has so many problems
but yet if I go up and
put my message, or my name
or whatever I want and
that's deemed illegal
but then there's a sign and then there's
all these other things from the city,
and promotions for politicians
and everybody trying to get elected
and all of that is not only
illegal in it's own right
but it's eye pollution
and it's something that
we don't wanna see.
Calvin Klein ads and things like that.
Los Angeles, California's
diversity is based upon
the fact that not only do
we celebrate graffiti here
but when you get well known enough
you're actually elevated
to celebrity status
which is kind of a conundrum
when you think about it.
If something is illegal and
then you're really good at it
then now you're an artist and
now you go to the art world
and make lots of money.
But how do you bridge the
gap from being a tagger
and something illegal and
to make it into mainstream?
Well, I have found that
majority of people sell out,
I guess is what you would call it.
They stop doing graffiti.
If they ever did do illegal
graffiti like myself,
they don't do it like I do.
They sneak around at nighttime.
They wear hoods and masks.
They get drunk.
They get liquid courage.
They go into train yards.
They get their friends around them
because they're scared to be
in these bad neighborhoods.
Every day that I paint
in downtown Los Angeles
I am going to be confronted
by somebody in a negative way
and I know and understand this,
and this is a risk that
I'm willing to take
but whether its an 18th street gang member
telling me that this is his territory
and that he's working here
or a security guard, a police
officer, a business owner,
another graffiti writer, anybody,
I'm going to run into
one of them guaranteed.
But what separates me, I don't fuckin run.
Ever.
I own that shit.
And so when somebody confronts you,
not only do they not understand
why are you not running
but they respect you for that,
even if it is their building
and you turn around and talk
to them and tell them why,
even if he doesn't agree with it,
he's not going to punch you, shoot you
because not only am I articulate
and I'm telling him exactly what I'm doing
this is the first time that
he's ever spoken or confronted
what he would consider a
tagger or a graffiti writer
and this guy is not what he thought.
And so my appearance and
my art looks abrasive
and I totally understand that,
because it's supposed to,
but it's a reflection of
who I am and where I'm from.
So, doing what I do
here wouldn't make sense
in another city or another place
because not only would
it not be celebrated,
it would be viewed as negative.
But here people around the
world look at what I do here
and copy it around the world.
So to me that lets me know
not only do I have influence
but because I'm in Los Angeles, California
it makes it extremely different.
Nobody cares if you paint in the middle of
the wilderness in Colorado.
Nobody gives a shit if
you go and do graffiti
in the back of your
mom's backyard on a shed,
no matter how impressive it is,
because there was no risk involved.
So for me, that I think is
one of the biggest things
is that not only am I possibly
going to lose my freedom,
which I have.
Get beaten severely which
recently this was a result
of some poor decisions on my behalf
directly caused from painting
and then the steps...
- [Interviewer] Yeah you got
a couple black eyes right now.
- Yes.
The black eyes, I was in a hospital
for a good day and a half.
They had to do a lot of tests.
I had some severe bleeding
issues not only in my face
but other areas of the body,
but I'm not sure how good
you can see these scars
but the one right here...
- [Interviewer] Oh yeah.
- This was somebody's teeth.
This one along the top was
my head being split open
with a pipe.
This one across the forehead
I was beaten with hammers
in an alley not too far
from here because...
- [Interviewer] These are different?
- These are all different
instances but these are all
injuries directly related to
graffiti because somebody,
in my opinion, did something
that they shouldn't have.
Basically disrespected me, went over me,
wrote some stupid message
that was not conducive to reality.
They see me, they fall down really fast,
I leave very quickly and they tell on me.
That's been a repetitive
cycle throughout my life
and at some point most graffiti writers,
at about from the age
of fourteen to twenty
they come faced with life decisions,
which is I got a job, I
got arrested, I have a kid,
this is juvenile activity
and I can't continue this.
And so they stop.
Or here in Los Angeles,
this is something different
from a lot of places,
they write graffiti in the
neighborhood where they're from
but the gangs are so deep in these areas
where graffiti is predominant,
that the gangs confront
the people doing graffiti
and now they tell them
hey, not only can you not do that here
but you're disrespecting us,
cause this is our territory
so by you writing your name
you're saying that this is your territory.
So instead of us fucking you up,
because we know who you
are and where you live,
we can just allow you
to keep doing graffiti
but now you're gonna write the gang name
because you're from this hood anyway.
So the little kid who had no intention
of ever being a gang member
because he was a little
writer, or tagger, or artist
is now a full fledged gang member
because he didn't have a choice.
He didn't want to, but now that he is,
he still gets to practice
that act of graffiti
and there's a lot of
gangs here in Los Angeles
that started as taggers
and their gang name
is a tagger name but
now it's a full on gang.
- [Interviewer] So you
been arrested for this?
- You know up until recently
I had never been arrested
and prosecuted for graffiti.
I've been stopped, I get
stopped almost on a daily basis
and people don't understand this,
they want to know how
do you not get arrested?
Oh trust and believe
me, I do get arrested.
I've never been prosecuted.
They've never filed charges.
They've dismissed them, they've let me go,
I talked my way out of it, I you know,
things of that nature.
But just recently I was arrested on
East LA, Soto and Olympic,
underneath a bridge painting
and I was with a group of people
that were from out of town
and they got, obviously,
a little agitated,
or not agitated but they
got a little concerned
when the police came.
And I said don't worry about
it, I'll take care of it.
And when I went and approached the police,
it's because I deal with
this on a daily basis
and I thought that it wasn't
going to be a bad situation.
Unfortunately, I was wrong.
They told me to get down on the ground
and I was ultimately
arrested for felony vandalism
and when I went to court
the case was not filed
and I was very happy, but
I'm currently out on bail
for an assault charge.
And I got out of prison on my last case
for aggravated assault,
which is the exact same charge
that I'm on bail for now.
But, when I got arrested for graffiti,
you cannot get arrested
while you're out on bail,
which I did.
So, I bailed out on that one
before my other bail
company could find out.
But when I went to court, they dropped it.
Well I got a letter in the mail yesterday,
they just filed it.
So not only did they just
file the graffiti charge
that I thought was dropped,
this incident with the black eyes,
I got another assault case.
And so now, I'm on bail for assault case,
felony vandalism, got
an assault case pending,
all three of these pending,
and I still do graffiti every day.
- [Interviewer] So, let's
say I'm a business owner.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] All right,
I rent a space somewhere.
And I am proud of my new business...
- Yes.
And we clean it up and make it perfect
and that's my new place of business.
And then one day I show up for work
and there's graffiti
all over the building.
How do you justify that?
- It depends on...
- [Interviewer] Cause I didn't
approve it, I didn't want it.
- Absolutely, and so,
every graffiti writer
has certain things that
they're willing to respect.
Me personally, I respect
people's personal property.
I would never write on
somebody's vehicle or their home.
Now, you mentioned a business,
it depends on where that
business is located.
If you were in downtown LA
or in downtown Skid Row,
your shit's fair game and the reason being
is because it's such a bad neighborhood
that this artwork whether
it's gang writing,
traditional graffiti,
propaganda, wheat pasting,
road signs, there's gonna
be some sort of graffiti
on your building whether I do
it or somebody else does it.
But if you have a new
building in a nice area,
I would never touch that building.
And the reason being,
is because not only am I
a business man, and I have my own business
and my own studio,
I wouldn't want somebody
to do that to my shit.
But the thing of it is,
everybody's different.
So when I was painting on
a business very near here,
the business owner came out
and in the commission of doing this
he threatened me with a gun
and said what in the
world would possess you
to stand here so brazenly and
disrespect me and my business?
And I said, I beg to
differ, what's your name?
And he didn't want to shake my hand
but it caused him to pause,
and so when I asked him what his name was,
I said my name is Asher and
I'm actually your neighbor
and I live right down the street
and I have a studio across the street
and your building was covered with garbage
and so I was covering it up in a way
that I thought looked better.
But I didn't mean to offend you
and you don't own this building,
but I understand that you own it
and now that I've met you,
I won't continue to do this
but since I started you should
at least allow me to finish.
And he said absolutely not,
because I have this gun doesn't
mean I'm afraid to use it,
but I don't like my neighbors whatsoever,
so please do it next door.
So I just changed my camera
that I was recording,
and I shifted it and I went
and finished it next door.
So, I mean, it kinda just
depends on a case by case basis.
And I think in my view of things it's okay
but it's because it's already there
or it's already going to happen.
But I definitely wouldn't
want it on my home
or my business, a school, or a church.
You know, things of that
nature, but that's me.
I'm in my forties, I'm an old school guy,
but new kids, new people,
you have to give respect
in order to receive it
and if they're from the
street, if they're from a gang
and a crew that does this graffiti
and they're proud of being vandals
then that's what they wanna do.
The point is to vandalize shit, you know?
It's because they're seeking an identity
and that's what it is
about is fuck the system,
stick it to the man, we don't pay taxes,
we steal our supplies, we don't
abide by rules and a society
because it's a bunch of shit and lies
and we're artists, and
we're young, and we're free,
and we're fuckin wild and we
can do whatever we choose.
But, let's just be honest,
that self destructive behavior
is only gonna get you so far.
And so, I've been dealing
with this for a long time
and people ask me why
do you keep doing this?
Like, you have children,
you have grandchildren,
you're successful, you're celebrated,
why haven't you started
doing something else?
Why haven't you sta...and
what do you get out of this?
Headaches.
But it's my passion and it's
who I am and I don't believe
that I'm gonna perish,
that I'm gonna go to jail.
Even though I'm a pendejo,
and I'm state raised
and this is who I am.
I used to feel like this negativity
but now I realize that
this is not only who I am,
but it brought me to this point.
And so, if I didn't go
through those negativity
and those trials of prison,
especially as a young man,
I wouldn't be where I am now.
But, unfortunately for me, I'm
still carrying a lot of that
misperception of masculinity.
So, god forbid somebody step
on my shoes or bump into me
because I'm gonna assault you immediately
without thinking about it.
And then, immediately after
doing so I'm gonna realize
oh shit, you messed up.
And so, when I was young my
dad used to always ask me,
even though we didn't live together,
he would always say
what's the matter with you?
What's the matter with you?
You don't think!
And it got to the point where
I started thinking there was
something wrong with me.
You know like, maybe I
do have a mental problem
because if I punch this guy,
or if I paint on this guy's building
and I get arrested or I go to jail,
that's not only not smart,
but that's self destructive
so maybe he's right.
But in reality, it wasn't
until I started painting
severe consequences like going to jail,
like losing my freedom, like
being alienated from my family,
that I started to slowly
think about things.
But now fast forward
twenty five years later,
why am I still doing it?
I don't believe I'm doing anything wrong.
I think society's the one with the problem
and I think that when I
have my first solo art show
in a gallery in downtown
Los Angeles this year,
and I make an extensive amount of money,
and then I start traveling the world,
now everybody's gonna say
oh look, this is my
nephew, this is my brother!
Oh look how proud I am
of my family member,
he's so successful!
And only because of monetary value
or because I'm doing it in a gallery?
So if I'm a successful tattooer
instead of painting the street
or instead of doing canvasses,
so I choose my canvass and I choose my art
and where I choose to put it,
but you're only celebrated
in certain ways.
And I think that that
is not only ridiculous
but I am willing to deal
with the consequences
because, authenticity cannot
be faked or duplicated.
And, real will always rise to the top.
So, some people aren't the best hustlers,
some people can't sell their
art, some people have the best
art ability but don't have the hustle
or the knowledge of finances.
My thing is, I have no fucking
interest in those things!
I'm a minimalist and I love being out here
and the fact that I'm
not doing life in prison,
the fact that I can walk outside my studio
on Skid Row and for the price
of a dollar can of spray paint,
paint anywhere in Los Angeles
knowing it'll reach to
the far ends of the world
via the internet, I'm the
happiest guy on earth.
I might not have a dollar
to my name at some point.
I might be facing over a decade in prison.
Single.
All these things against me.
But in reality, I'm the
happiest that I've ever been
because I'm living my dream
and I don't care what anybody says,
I'm a part of history.
And not only am I in the history books,
I'm in the concrete in
downtown Los Angeles,
that shit is never going anywhere,
I'm in the history books.
I'm on the rooftop of this building,
the front of the street,
downtown, everywhere.
OG Asher Lokes, downtown Skid
Row, Los Angeles, California.
Watch out for me.
- [Interviewer] All right Asher.
Thank you very much.
- [Asher] Thank you.